serious serious what's the least amount
of money you have to accept to sell your
business I just asked you make up the
number yourself for JK JK and barbell
that's weird I'll do one at a time okay
fine that's weird my brain doesn't work
like that it's not smart like Anthony's
one at a time [ __ ] hey good good
impression you went straight to [ __ ]
autistic you became Anthony holy [ __ ]
that was good JK probably 10 million why
the [ __ ] are we here
[ __ ] are we doing that's a good amount
oh what the [ __ ] are you getting paid
dude
is enough for me and Joe to have I don't
know two to like three million each we
take the rest we split almost everyone
has been rocking with us it's [ __ ]
sick 10 million you and Joe take two to
three million the rest is tax what about
barbell probably like 10. it's not so
much about maximizing the deal that's
not what I'm after we're totally talking
about money and maximizing oh I don't
care title of this video is maximizing
the deal